Hi Sam thank you so much for joining me
today what kind of shift in preparation
do you think chess 960 requires to
effectively prepare well it comes down a
lot more to what kind of form you're on
uh so for example if you're not on the
best form in classical chess but you're
really well prepared and you come into
the game better prepared your Pony to
come with a Time Advantage because
they're burning their clock while you're
playing out your preparation you come in
with a bit better on the board that can
make up for a bit but 960 is much more
about your present form uh and it's
funny I sort of had the idea that 960
really
tilts the balance heavily towards the
more talented types and away from the
hard-working types with that said uh the
lot I didn't manage to play 960 last
year but the year before in 2021 I
played against like the entire
grantchester field mid plus two finished
in second place so I definitely think
that I can play it well
um at least for my own preparation I
didn't check any 960 positions I didn't
play 8960 but you know I probably
averaged like 15 000 steps to have my
Fitbit for the last week just been
trying to get healthy get in good shape
and make sure that I'm full of energy
I'm I'm surprised to hear that I know
how much you're you're focusing on
Preparation in general of course but at
the same time how do you actually want
to prepare for 960. so for example I've
played two 960 events here at the club
one was a match with Maxine vessel
lagrav back in 2018 and I just got
clobbered and in fact I actually played
Four mock matches uh with four different
you know three different opponents four
mock matches in preparation for the
tournament to try to get a feel for 960.
and in fact one of the exact positions
we got showed up and when you just think
you know four out of 960 that's not
super likely and I think that one was
the only one that he 400 me so like it's
just like at some point I just threw my
hands up in the air like you know the
preparation for 960 just isn't really a
thing and then when I came in totally
blank in 2021 I had just made a very
deep run at the World Cup I made it to
the quarterfinal came straight here for
the rapid and blood slim the same field
Cup right after I just came with no rest
no preparation whatsoever and I came in
and made plus two against the GCT field
so uh that was um it sort of got me
thinking that for 960 preparation just
doesn't matter much but your form your
mood these are the things that that
matter a lot and so I've you know been
trying to be full of energy basically
um Bobby Fischer uh was mentioning that
the most important ability in chess is
spatial perception what do you think is
more important is a pattern recognition
visualization maybe the pawn structure
for to be prepared for chess 960. I
think it's all a big part of it it's
like asking a soccer player what's more
important running dribbling passing or
shooting I mean like you you need all of
it or you're going to be useless
um and when you have all these sort of
very broadly categorized parts of Chess
excellence and you say well which one is
the most important it to me it just
feels like any of the ones that you
mentioned if you're lacking it you're
not going to make it and so you know
pointing to one element of Chess playing
that this is the most important part I
just don't really buy it
um if you put a gun to my head and said
tell me I would say definitely like
tactical pattern recognition especially
when uh even though this is not put at
Blitz time control it's rapid it feels
often more like faster Rapid or Blitz
just because in normal games you'll be
playing out 10 15 20 moves of theory and
even then you'll have a pretty good
understanding of how your pieces are
supposed to coordinate in the middle
game and here you just don't have that
so even from the very beginning of the
game you're burning a lot of time so I
definitely think that being able to play
quickly and notice patterns is probably
going to be the most important part
you've written a few books and uh
created a few accessible courses as well
what do you think would be a good advice
to give players who are trying to
improve their visualization skills just
do endless calculation exercises it's a
good start another one that I've heard
is if you're looking for specifically
visualization is you can take some
extremely easy puzzle like Checkmate in
one or Checkmate into uh blindfold
yourself and have someone call out the
pieces one by one where they are until
the position is complete so this way
because the position is so easy to solve
in terms of its actual chess playing
ability uh you're the only real test is
can you memorize the whatever 18 pieces
that are on the board at this point and
find like the easy one so that's one
thing I could recommend for uh
visualization but yeah I mean I've
definitely done a lot of work on trust
content but I've viewed my books and
stuff very differently than most people
I don't write them to try to sell them I
write them for a very specific reason
because I want to study these topics and
I want to get better at chess and
forcing myself to study these topics and
then present them in a clear and
coherent manner will increase my
understanding of them and actually my
next book coming out is theoretical Rook
end games which has been a three and a
half year uh journey and uh really
improve my knowledge of Rook on games a
lot we're really looking forward to that
final question Sam you've mentioned in
your video before the event that you're
looking forward the most to play against
Gary casparov is he the only player
you're looking forward to playing
against in this competition I wouldn't
say he's the only one I'm looking
forward to playing is but all these
other guys I play them all the time like
like every single other player in this
tournament must have played like five
ten times before both in classical and
rap but in everything and it's not like
they're bad players or anything they're
very very good and I'm delighted to play
with them too and I'm glad to be playing
a very strong event alongside them but
you know Gary Kasparov is my biggest
childhood Hero by far when I met him for
the first time when I was 16 I was a
very talented kid coming up but I had
never met any really strong players I
had never had any real proper formal
chess running and he completely opened
my eyes to the level of Excellence that
uh human beings are capable of and
inspired me in a way that nobody else
ever did and I owe a huge amount of how
far I've today so just that you know
short meeting I had with Gary Kasparov
and he was and so the opportunity to
play with him is obviously tremendous
and you know the one complaint I sort of
have about 960 is that because you don't
know any strategy in the beginning of
the game you sort of have to guess where
your pieces belong and if you guess
wrong you can just lose so for example
the last time I played 960.
um four games that just felt like I
didn't play I beat Hikaru and Wesley in
like 15 moves each and I lost to Gary
and maximum in like 15 moves each and
the other five games are fantastic but
between those four there wasn't much
play and you know to face my biggest
childhood hero and just get completely
clobbered in like 10 moves because I
didn't know where the pieces were
supposed to go and he guessed better I
mean I shouldn't say he gets better he
figured it out better but I'm really
looking forward to playing with him
again
thank you
[Music]